it's really pathetic deal that's the
verdict on the Prime Minister zine
negotiations from the UK bleeder
Nigel Faraj as you might rather expect
he joins me now and a very good morning
to you mr. price I want to start asking
you a first offer you got a debate Alex
Salmond on this program he threw down
the gauntlet to me I know he did yeah
last week the other week I was
challenged by the First Minister of
Wales Carwyn Jones to go down to Cardiff
and debate with him which I did and I'm
very keen to debate Nicola Sturgeon she
is the first Alex Salmond it will say
well Alex Salmond was a very very big
figure I mean he was he was the leader
in the referendum campaign
he's not even leader of the SNP in
Westminster so look the deal is so you
think he's gonna say I'll say I'll say
yes to Alex Salmond and Nicola Sturgeon
let's have you know a couple on each
side and let's do a big Scottish but not
just Alex Salmond on his own that's it
that's who my but that's the extent of
what lies because articulate the
arguments very well it would be good for
the Audis a debate Nicola Sturgeon
absolutely she's the one in the seat
she's the one in this campaign making
the big arguments in Scotland I'd like
to debate so you turning down Alex Anat
lets us be clear I've asked you Nicola
Sturgeon whether she would like to do a
debate now if she turns me down
I'll consider very seriously Alex well
one will go in let's just see what Alex
Salmond see Alex Salmond
offering you the challenge there I'll be
delighted to to take on mr. Fraser or
any commonly and the anti-european side
I mean I don't know if they're quite
decided who they'll be fielding yet and
they seem to spend a lot of time
fighting with each other that's the sort
of folk thought they are but yes of
course you you debate all camels in a
referendum campaign so not head-to-head
well I didn't know he was leading the
SNP cam but I thought Nicola Sturgeon
was anyway there we are I'm very happy
to go to Edinburgh or Glasgow or invar
now here well anywhere else
oh no we've got to do it it's gone all
right then well there we are
well you can come to Scotland you're on
your own there I mean he made an
interesting point there Alex Salmond who
is leading the camp okay so hopefully
you know hopefully no one individual
because if one individual means it will
be a disaster there is this if you reach
those newspapers and listen to today's
debate you would think the only people
eligible to vote in this referendum are
conservative voters
it is balderdash 80% of those eligible
to vote in the general election did not
vote conservative there are millions of
non voters out
that are interested in this su and
everyone's forgotten about the trade
union movement about Labor
you know we to win this referendum we
need different messengers to read
different parts of the Electra so you're
quite happy I mean you know they regard
you as toxic don't they they
conservative cause they don't want to
have anything to do no Lord no I'm
beneath them I'm far too common to have
anything to do with them I mean I
understand that look there are lots of
people in the Conservative Party that
will share platforms with me and have
done over the last few weeks and and I
think we're going to see they were going
to see an out campaign with lots and
lots of different individuals
representing the full rainbow spectrum
of British politics and that's exactly
as it should be so on Friday night what
did you discuss with George Galloway did
you share your views on Iran together we
didn't go through Israel we didn't go
through economic policy in fact if we
discussed almost anything in UKIP's
manifesto last year we've had a very
hard time to ask him to join the ucae
brand he was a well quite he was very
disciplining about me last year I mean
in quite personal terms but here's the
point George Galloway and I disagree
fundamentally but we agree on the single
most important little question we will
face in our lifetimes mainly are we to
get back our independence but also
prepare many people I'll talk about the
public meetings you go to you think it
cancels it cancels it out because you
know you are marmite politicians to two
different sides within the debate what
do you think then people are looking why
don't you move that the three people are
looking at you and George Galloway and
going right okay well I don't want to
touch Nigel fries but with a bargepole
but I will vote for George Galloway and
the other way round we had Seville cash
on the plaque or doesn't know we hadn't
make know we had ruling the economists
on the platform and we had Kate Hoey the
Labour MP on the platform and we had a
dozen speakers on that platform
representing a huge range of different
political families and what we've done
is to sign a pledge and the pledge is we
cast aside all differences all previous
quarrels
for this period of the referendum to put
the national interest first but would
you do it again what do you what you
know with the best one to make when you
see those photographs in the paper of
him with his trilby on or whatever it is
and you beaming into his eyes they would
you do that again with the best will in
the world I could try as hard as I like
I don't think I've got a great pull I'm
the Muslim community in this country but
George does George actually speaks to
that community he also speaks to a lot
of people who at the moment are remain
voters as we saw in the Scottish
referendum he's a powerful debater he is
a big figure on the left of British
politics and he will do what he does and
I will do what I do and I would
encourage people to grow up to get
beyond tribalism to get beyond the
pettiness that poisons our politics most
poke most weeks of the year and to say
if we believe in this country we must
all work together what's your take on
Boris Johnson do you think he's good
kind of join him perhaps join you on one
of those platforms or something look at
that photograph there he's got some
interesting apps to wear as well gee I
mean you think Boris Johnson is going to
come over yes I do actually based on any
information beyond instinct did you try
to his sister but she wasn't giving in
the mega way yeah yeah I had look I I
think he will and hurrah
is all I can say to that because what
again I think a lot of the commentary
and Westminster don't understand is
there are literally only five or six
people in this referendum who's
campaigning whose presence can sway the
undecided and he is one of those Harford
and if he comes in on that side do you
think it would destroy the Prime
Minister if he wins I don't care about
that you don't like the Prime Minister
don't you I'm not interested in
political parties I'm not interested in
the Prime Minister I'm interested in
winning this referendum and again too
much of this debate is about positioning
what happens afterwards let's just run
win the referendum at all I care about
and it's often said you know whichever
the result whichever way it falls it's
end of your parties I mean it's really a
single-issue party I mean if you if you
get out then you've achieved it endure
if we're in we're in for generations to
come there's no point in you KITT I
repeat the point I want to win the
referendum you can speculate all you
like about what happened in the next few
years the fact is if we vote to leave we
then need to make sure that the British
government carries out the will of the
people and I say that because the Danes
voted against Maastricht and the forced
to vote again twice the Irish have voted
against treaties and they were forced to
vote again and the French and Dutch
torpedoed the the European Constitution
and yet it was introduced someone who's
about so actually you Kip will need to
be very
on to make sure they carry out the will
of a distaff you mentioned earlier
--is-- i mean you know there's obviously
special arrangements between the UK and
ireland in its citizens who live here
being able to vote in general elections
they're going to be able to vote in this
new referendum they're having a general
election of course sir yeah in ireland
next week I was over there recently and
you've got the petition of the Prime
Minister they're urging all Irish people
in the UK to vote to remain yeah what he
would do I mean he is he is completely
sold on the euro but I think these EU
Nationals should have the vote project
what Ireland's different islands
completely different our history our
shared relationship the fact that since
1921 we've had you know our own special
deal it's not comparable to Bulgaria or
Hungary or anywhere else it just isn't
comparable but but I mean look the Irish
political class are completely sold out
on the European project they signed up
to the euro which has been a disaster
for them and yet the Irish people are
pretty I tell you what there was euro
skeptic as well I just oh one other
thing on eligibility to vote something I
read the other that was interesting
maybe you saw it as well at British
embassies within the European Union
Italy and France were mentioned
encouraging people expats British expats
to sign up to vote do you read something
more into that
well the Foreign Office is neutral I
mean the Foreign Office has been
campaigning for the European Union now
for decades I have to work with them
occasionally in Brussels there is no
attempt at civil service neutrality they
will do what they can to help their
friend the Prime Minister